audio audio audio audio we are good
okay
hello everyone and welcome
to the second year
of my favorite stream i've ever done
what is going to happen over the next i
think couple of hours um depends how how
much we have to donate
is that
tiltify is currently talking to me on a
separate chat
and they are going through and finding
streamers who are raising money this
holiday season for different charitable
courses
um we will be
live
donating
thousands of dollars i assume
to
their charity streams um
some of these people last year had zero
viewers i was their only viewer then we
donate thousands of dollars and then you
see their reactions and it is wonderful
all in the name of charity the money is
tiltify's money it is not my money um
but they will be donating it in my name
as part of clause my cause which is
ongoing i have the hashtag in
my twitch buyer right now um
and i'm expecting to basically just see
a lot of very happy people uh
so
how am i okay let me mute
this here
and
uh
that's kind of it we just we just find
him we donate money to him um okay let
me let them know okay
i'm ready to go
we gotta make sure
they are ready on the first one
which
is wonderful
um
i don't know how i don't want to say
this because i don't want anyone to ruin
it oh this is exciting oh this is super
exciting
okay
okay okay don't go in and spoil it too
soon is is what i will say all right
please
don't go in and spoil it too soon
we have
their stream we unmute
and we
at this point
she's currently raising money for them
back up too i turned them down for a
little bit that was like rats
it's for the
vents in front of emperor
got that
one
okay i'll have to do it off to this one
so i can have my mic i know the only
face cam wanted as well this is a
12-hour
charity stream she's doing i saw another
person
just me and one other person that's
incredible i guess their work is
look how cute she looks
[Music]
i'm staying with someone because i just
saw something i didn't need we got a
reaction
hasn't shown up here when we got the
reaction
holy [ __ ]
okay it's at 1 500. my god one thousand
i was in communication
with alan pierce
hit me alan
[Music]
if you guys want to jump in and send her
love we can do that too
what
it's so wonderful
i think the thought oh there it is it
showed up it showed up it showed up dude
thank you so much
holy
oh my god
oh oh someone just downloaded it and
yeah if you would like to go
be nice you can jump over there wow
classic allen
so like the fact that people don't stop
smiling
is so
cute
[Laughter]
oh hello jeff i see you there jeff
all at once allen's a great guy it's
true he's a great guy he's a great guy
oh i'm sorry i don't want this last name
charlie
that's me
that's me
that's good
there's a lot of my people i can't
believe it guys that's a lot of tomatoes
oh my god
okay hang on let me fix my face cam real
quick oh we have to do this scooter
griffin
thank you for the fish
marry me and then the shelter let me
bring carol's ankles again
this oh my god that's 1500 y'all can
marry
oh my gosh thank you wait what happened
it's so nice okay okay and then we put
um
one beautiful don't know all the love
wow guys check i'm trying to be like
please check out allen's channel can we
give him a shout out i'm gonna check out
his channel
love allen
[Laughter]
that's amazing what a great guy what a
great guy oh boy give me a second y'all
this is the hardest task
and then there's three people in the
cafeteria right now
she didn't get killed either what game
were y'all playing tonight
you didn't get rated you did not get
rated
you think you did but you didn't holy
[ __ ]
but riley's been in reactor
okay
vote quick quack
well they changed the whole ui
i haven't played the game in a while
okay um okay let me i'm dead i can't
grab
the next one
we have to know what's going on
you're not left like the meeting or
report bodies
um okay there are no kill shelter
i do like hearing people explaining
i just want to kick in where
you know they do euthanize them so right
now i'm just going to write woo in a
chat
wow
that's going to get a lot of dogs yay
animals
thank you thank
you wow
scooter gaming wait what happened
i want to make sure i didn't miss anyone
welcome bowsers thank you again
okay
okay i'll go do my test uh let me pull
over
the next one
all right
like your friends
we good
we good to go this is
i'm the best man oh she's got all the
fancy christmas stuff going on here
why am i hearing
i can still hear the other one there we
go
this is this is these are hardcore gamer
hours we're about to break through right
here and here's the last this is
hardcore gaming going down right now
look at it uh they stopped chasing
ghosts
oh you're right it is very fast no he's
dumb
no he's dumb
okay focus for those kills
so they're they're raising money for
toys for tots which is awesome
this is also a 12-hour charity stream oh
my gosh
i love that people are so willing to do
this
[Music]
i think this is going to shock them
because of how hardcore these gamer
albums are is what i'm saying leaving
goodbye
[Music]
i can't move your screen look at bubba
it's a lot of audio a lot of audio can't
tell ghost won't turn their camera yeah
he is oh oh yeah
oh yeah he's keeping ghost in the stain
in the stain
eat palettes bubba right i mean grimmy
once you back him
[Music]
not yet nothing yet there there it is
there it is where is it it's there
she's just got to see we're going to go
tv yeah
ghost is it's there
look at it the 2000 it happened it's on
the screen i get again i get it these
are hardcore gamer hours
i i respect it you've got to get through
you're dead by daylight
oh my god
does he even see you
there
nobody go in there and spoil it there's
already one person don't do it don't do
it don't spoil it we gotta wait
she's gonna she's why did you give him a
three game it hot and she's gonna be
shook
satisfying for me to teabag him
i don't actually care it's a very loud
game it is a very loud but i don't want
to get on him to get a 3k oh well so he
continues to suck and he'll never and
he'll never learn from his mistakes
which means that he will eventually be
consistently
consistent
and bullied on and shut it off
i'm like no just leave don't give him a
tear you know what i'm doing with real
quick you know i'm giving her a 3k
they're reading i'm trusting his mmr so
he gets [ __ ] on by the australians
[Applause]
[ __ ] nope i'll give you that i'll
give you that
[Music]
buddy come on enjoy a higher mmr that
you can't actually handle because you're
garbage come on i'll give you that you
got it you've got to be looking at it
soon enjoying
here comes alan
look you just gotta look at the
donations you just gotta look at it
i don't i could go in there and and say
hey look at look at the donation but sad
but i don't wanna i of want to wait okay
okay the game's over surely camping
camping
face camping a face camping insidious
bubba
vegetation noed iron grass inside yes
kavanaugh uh-huh that is absolutely a
hundred percent garbage face camping
bubble uh
that's you come on did you say no in do
you say know it oh yeah
i might have to let them know but i
really want them to just see it
i don't want to spoil it just in case
you y'all be careful i saw a follower in
there you all be careful
i remember you from last year
michael
if i'm saying it wrong just let me know
visually michael
okay i gotta i got it for the follower
welcome in okay
i wrote what are you raising money for
you have to deal with him you'll [ __ ]
see you'll [ __ ] shatter
that was such trash
what am i raising money for uh we are
raising money for toys for tots tonight
um we are trying to do a charity stream
to get as much money as we can how much
have you ready to make holidays whatever
holiday they celebrate better for for
kids this year for the holiday season
yeah so i said how much have you raised
some giveaways and
we're holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that has to be broken
oh my god that's so funny
because my comments
is literally
go check yourself if i write the [ __ ]
now
there's a
1740 donation
oh my god i holy [ __ ] that's incredible
[Laughter]
someone just donated 1700 oh that's cool
[Laughter]
holy crap
i think you hit your goal oh my gosh um
[Laughter]
is that what you came in to ask for was
that you did you make that donation
oh my god look at it
i love how much of your race holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
that's incorporated congratulations
inferno you've managed to raise two
thousand dollars for toys
oh my god you guys
you guys are [ __ ] heroes
it makes me cry welcome in all of you
you guys are [ __ ] oh god
amazing that was my favorite i am shook
i am absolutely shocked you guys are
[ __ ] amazing shout out
shout out absolutely which one
who
wherever the donation is please speak up
so i can [ __ ] actually shout them out
please yes please
a love read you guys are amazing oh my
god thank you welcome in also oh my god
i'm going to cry you guys are [ __ ]
awesome that is amazing i i can't wait
to watch that playback i'm going to
[ __ ] cry okay didn't she have a bunch
of donation goals oh my god that's great
ah
i'm so happy
it was the aussie
you guys always the audience yeah i was
amazing you were talking [ __ ] like
absolutely amazing five minutes before
so much
thank you so much what donation goals
did you have that you now have i was
hoping to get maybe a third of my goal
and i was hoping i would get that far
mostly giveaways actually great for the
kids but look at this look at this
guys
we are pick my new agent
we are at 2010
oh my god we are actually over our goal
holy [ __ ] guys you guys are amazing
thank you for the follows what's up
thank you for coming in you guys are
making me cry you guys are making me cry
oh my god
you are totally making me cry i am i am
shook i am so shook
thank you that also means wow we have
three giveaways to do
we have three gift card giveaways to do
the tattoo of my favorite
my full donation to
uh toys for tots literacy program
because my goal i have goal matching
so i was putting in up to 100 of my own
money to match goals um for toys for
tots literacy programs so i'll be making
a hundred dollar donation to toys for
tots literacy on top of the donation you
guys just made
so that money goes to toys for tots and
then i'll be making a separate donation
to toys for tots literacy um to make to
put in a hundred dollars of my own and
oh my god i want to watch that backstage
so bad i want to watch it so bad
yeah
what's the title tell them what to do to
enter the giveaways i also tell me about
the tap what's the
is it still um bang toy boy
if you type exclamation point toy into
the chat exclamation point toy t-o-y you
will be entered in the next giveaway we
are giving away steam and amazon gift
cards that's right all of you should go
do steam and amazon gift cards so if you
you're entered into the next one if you
put exclamation point
exclamation toy into the chat you're
entering the next giveaway and for the
rest of the stream i've got to go put on
a onesie because i promised you guys a
blue dinosaur onesie for the rest of my
stream if we get that gold yeah well
daleks doing this giveaway and as for
the tat
it's a chat vote
i have four choices for you and you all
get to vote i really hope we get to say
charizard not my choice but can your
choice but can it be charizard thousand
dollars to toys for tots
yeah
you get to put ink on me your choice
that's awesome so i'll i'm going to let
dalek do the giveaways
thank you people the canopy chairs
aren't talking it wasn't one of my it
wasn't one of my choices but you know
what i will i will add it i will add it
to the choices i will add charizard to
the choices
because you did this i will add it to
the choices that's basically getting a
tattoo
absolutely 100 i'm not even a pokemon
player but i would do it because that's
actually my favorite pokemon charizard
and evie charizards and evie were my two
favorite very good very good very good i
i know some of them so i would actually
pick one of those that's great so okay
this person is going to get a charizard
tattoo let me get let me get down to do
the giveaways and then i will put then
we'll do a poll in the chat we'll do the
voters we'll let you vote in the chat
for what it's going to be
and let me get the um
gotta go get a one second oh my god
thank you for all the follows i can't
even keep up with you guys i can't even
keep up with you guys thank you for all
the follows you guys are [ __ ] amazing
i can't even go i can't even keep up
with all the names you guys are yeah
that bar just went foom
it just formed
and it took so long you didn't even see
the food that's the best guy you didn't
even see the balloon
oh my gosh
that's a good suggestion dad hubris they
said uh a charizard with a so that's a
name
that's awesome
i am absolutely shocked you guys [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] amazing let me see it
let me get the somebody has an already
actual list please clip that for me that
let me get the actual list up for you
guys my favorite
give me half a second because i just
need to find this for you guys i
actually have it up i haven't listed
all the time you don't have to i won't
make you vote on there so
i do have
i do have a
all the votes went into genji's paw
print
but let me put that's pretty cool let me
put up the
actual oh my god guys thank you for all
the followers oh thank you so much for
watching thank you all for what you've
done this is
spectacular beyond my wildest
expectations
really i did not i put that goal up
there as a stretch
and i didn't
i didn't truly expect to get there i
hope but i didn't truly expect okay good
as long as we didn't ruin this person's
skin
it's just
[ __ ] amazing it is
fantastic
absolutely fantastic ghost that's fine i
get you if you have finals by all means
this is gonna take up my time for a
little bit so if you need to dip i fi i
totally get it but again amazing
um
let me put up the actual pool and i'll
add charizard to it because you
[ __ ] earned that
okay
let's go number one playstation employee
alana pierce look at me let me whoa
like get it get it tattooed
a steam gift code i have a charizard
tattoo nice i have no regrets let me get
this up there for you guys
i'll have dalek put up a poll too i will
also definitely get a god of war tattoo
you should be able to
i believe in you
okay you may believe with me
okay let me add this in
wow guys
one more roll
this is [ __ ]
amazing this is [ __ ] amazing
this is just amazing
thank you for joining me right have a
good night three
two
i have a one block of chocolate that i'm
also going to eat what i'm going to do
is it's the original four items that i
was putting up for the tattoo i will get
one of those four
but if you vote for it i will add the
charizard to it so i will do that as
well like i'll add it to it oh my okay
like i don't know you guys will be there
for that yeah that's fair that's fair
yeah we're all right with that i'm
waiting here for this poll so
i'm ready let me dump it in the chat for
you can i actually do can i actually
dump it in the chat and then we'll jump
to the next one i'm just here for this
it's very important to me you can put it
up on the screen wait i can put it on
the screen what am i doing i'm stupid
okay she literally committed to getting
an extra tattoo
let me uh get this up on the screen for
you guys vote for it
that
okay i hear you
i hear you
all right you are getting a charizard my
friend
let me uh put it put an image up on
screen for you oh look at them that's so
cute
you guys
i don't even have words for this this is
just the most amazing thing okay i am so
absolutely amazed by this
let me get the next one ready get an
image of them up on screen for you this
is muted oh i muted both of them
i know you guys aren't all on my discord
so you didn't see these choices so let
me do this one's gonna be fun
okay there we go
all right i know you guys weren't part
of the discord so you didn't see these
choices but this was this is the tiltify
pole that's up
i'm pretty excited about this let's be
real quick swapping it over to the
there you
go so that was the poll that's the poll
that was up for
so that's what we voted for two choices
and like i said i will add the charizard
i can't spell but i will add the
charizard onto that as well but that's
the poll that was up for the tattoo
choices
so we'll actually let me actually get an
actual poll going so you guys can vote
because i'll jump back over so we can
vote but for now
i'm going to move to our next one
singing it
live without which is
thank you so
much which brings our grand total too i
think all right hold on let's see
here we're at um
he's figuring out his grand total stop
on his watch plus so they have their
counter is down here
650 of 800 raised for saint jude
it's an organization that i love to
support 795
please you don't go there and there and
spoil it let's make it so much um that's
really gonna mama bee's day
i'm using a calculator cockles
that's really gonna help the family
thank you so much y'all
call me leo hello catching up with chat
and low with the 30 donuts really cute
three dollars to the family thank you so
much
he's like mom why aren't you clapping
for twitch
let us know we're prioritizing all
dono's um requests
it's all going so fast we can make
requests
um
okay
mods are okay we've sent it mom do you
want to sing i want hippopotamus
i have no i have the karaoke so just
look up the lyrics
i love this so much how cute is this
my mom loves his song hippopota
what a cute idea to say hippopotamus
oh
i miss my mom
are you afraid to say hip-hop okay hang
on let me move up so that we can see it
there we go it jumped it jumped it
jumped
he was updated thank you kim
my mom's gonna sing you have to do it
for the stream i feel like maybe you've
got to get through the song before you
read the donations which i would respect
wait what audrey on it yes
okay hold on
do it mama b
don't make her sing hippopotamus
she likes the song though am i wrong
she's so cute
i'm stuck
oh
there it is
what
look at that
we're at 1850 somebody donated twelve
hundred dollars to saint jude
thank you
come on you got a little bit more from
mama b akka excuse me hold on let me go
back it is from alana pierce with 1200
uh clause my calls delivered oh yay
thank you so much
clausman can i thank you thank you thank
you request the song now we did it we
smashed the goal
oh my god like
way over okay
i hope they don't think they have to
sing all night now though
we're at 1850 now for st jude thank you
so much oh my goodness so cute pause my
cards close my cards thank you for the
follow big dave i can't type in the chat
because it's verified accounts only and
apparently my account's not verified
stretch goal
should we do that stretch school
should we push it to i mean it's we're
just shy of 2k let's do it why not yolo
i respect it that's what i do
we could do 2k
thank you so much
do i have a check i do have a check mark
it says verified accounts only oh we
just have to click on it
oh my bad goodness um
hi exactly what you need me a lot of
people no i'm not verified it needs me
to verify my phone number
for you now son of uh
you twitch i literally have a verified
check and it's like actually
we don't have your phone number so
that's not gonna work michael hi
actually kitty for the host as well
this is my mom mama bee i love her
um i love him we're gonna sing
hippopotamus i'm i okay i think we watch
hippopotamus
we watch hippopotamus
i'm here for the lurk hello going to be
lurking eating pumpkin bread oh nice
all right low take care oh i'm being
hate rate prevented well that's actually
kind of fair
yeah let me throw you guys the link
thanks for the reminder jared here you
go
i just want to see the hippopotamus song
of which i don't know
to be clear i don't think i actually
know this
oh the tattoo pulls up okay hang on
uh
in here
let's go let's go let's go add charizard
everybody
it's important
was there a raid did i miss what's
happening
did i miss a rain quick quick for
christmas it's very important for me
come on
i love that she spelled it wrong too a
true fantasy
um on uh on top of that we're also
raising money for um my immediate family
uh i lost my cousin to um cancer
last month and so we're helping um my
cousin doris and her family uh with that
so if you want to donate
back in the onesie virtual tip jar here
and this stream will go directly to them
and as far as i know my calculations are
correct we are just shy of 800 for them
so that's incredible and we're just shy
of 2k for st dude this is insane
this is insane
actually i'm gonna do an update for
instagram y'all
okay
hold on okay
y'all this is so crazy we're raising
money for saint jude's children
and we're just shy
we're just shy we'll jump over
here we go that's that's pretty on brand
so i promised i would do the rest of the
stream in a blue dinosaur onesie so you
guys win
you get the tat you get the onesie you
get all the giveaways everything
everything
[Laughter]
i can't even
i literally was crying i was literally
crying i had to take a moment because i
was literally crying
rodney this is the best thing ever look
at all the money
for the kids
look at all the money for the kids look
at all the money for the kids
hey what happened what happened here did
some of you come in to troll me to vote
the wrong thing intentionally oh my gosh
hey
look at that money for the kids look at
you know how many toys that is how do
you know how many toys that is
my own chat did that there's no way that
it wasn't you guys dude how many toys
that is
know how many kids are gonna be happy
i can't even
oh
i'm so happy this is so good
this is so good this is so wonderful
uh
genji has some fans he does
genji's my cat he's my co-streamer
oh that's actually really cute he's my
baby kitty that's actually very cute all
the little kitty icons and stuff that i
have around they're all genji
he's my little boy i think he's right
over here wait you guys have never met
him hang on
you guys it ended we did not get the
charizard and that is your fault
you got a big audience come here wow
that's
like one specific person really did that
huh
wow all right okay everybody
that's fine yeah we're gonna meet the
cat this is a little baby whose paw
print gets tattooed if he wins the vote
he did win the vote
this is genji cat
this is my little baby
he's like oh my god mom what are you
doing
he's like why are you making me look
like my friend
hi there this is my this is my baby
so when i respect it
i respect it you're getting your cat's
paw print this little baby
wow
moist bison yeah whoever these two
people are can we ban them from my chat
can you can you do that he's my
co-streamer he's like no he hates the
camera he's like oh they're doing it now
on christmas oh
and we have a ring
thank you
extreme edition
[Laughter]
goodness oh the focus that's so cute
i want a hippopotamus for christmas
because it's hard for me to
i love her
mama b
we have no choice but to stand this
doesn't get you fired up for the
holidays nothing but oh thanks devin
thank you so much for the raid mom we
gotta raid so we celebrate whoa
good job mommy
we should we can do it again if y'all
want to request it she has any concept
of what's happening
thank
i think my parents understand twitch
welcome raiders derek is in here hi
derek i'm also unverified my friend i
cannot contribute to the chat
okay we got a new one
let's
go
shout out to mama bee the long may she
live
alrighty
what's going on oh you deserve all of
them all the wonderful things in the
world
all the wonderful things in the world
it's good to see you
what's all this hello
hello i'm back i'm back hi elena hi get
a proper wave not not a big
head shake can i come back to come back
to us kyle yes exactly right oh it is
going to be dmca that is a good point i
might get in trouble have you tried just
being taller you know what i was
thinking of doing that what should i do
about that
i don't know what the solution is to
someone else playing music in the stream
uh
uh
i've never done it
before tiltify i will let you make the
call on what you want me to do it may
already be too long i don't know
i guess we have to pick another one yeah
i don't want to get in trouble
unfortunately
that's a bummer that's a real bummer how
are you allowed to do that don't you
automatically get in trouble for it
i've never even had a um
a uh
a copyright strike before oh no
oh is he still playing the music
maybe somebody could check
okay
we found another one
let's go i'm sorry friend you seem very
cool
oh [ __ ]
all right marion
oh look what i found
oh okay
presents
oh yeah
this is fortnite
i'm gonna grab the spidey thing oh
thanks for the raid bruce welcome
everybody
we're doing
the follow-up
to
my favorite stream i've ever done
with tiltify we are donating
thousands of dollars
to small streamers right now this person
has three viewers this is gonna be
incredible
get out of the storm i'm ready let's go
they are raising money or they've only
raised four dollars this one's gonna be
so good
they're raising money for starlight
we will drop the donut on them
and then
no link yet no link yet
donation first and then link
oh no this
get me is
it's there it went through and i think
that maybe it also created the overlay
on
on
her
on the the webcam maybe
okay okay this is i can we've dropped
the donation sometimes it takes him a
little while to notice
they had three four four dollars this
one's gonna be so good okay i love
waiting
i hear shooting
uh i can do the same thing in chat again
no no no we're gonna wait we're gonna
wait please nobody nobody spoil it
nobody spoil it
i'm coming
who's shooting
it's not me because i have no bullets
lady you need to back up you need to you
need to i think it's like in pot
because when you don't have perfectly
fine i have grenades a ton of followers
you're not expecting to get a donation
so you probably don't look that often
right and i see shots fired uh
yeah hey just gaming out here just
gaming
25 players remaining [ __ ] look at that
these are real gamer hours you're going
to get through it thank you stopping by
bruce thank you for the raid my friend
free screen everybody
i dropped the box great human 10 editor
i see him
just missed him
jefferson
damn it hello welcome balsteo welcome
welcome welcome
thank you lost arrow appreciate it
okay the storm eye is shrinking i hope
that they get the dub
i see a purple that they see the donut
and then we throw a bunch of viewers on
them sit down
okay take it back
that was bit harsh
jesus christ there's wolves everywhere
they did
is that
is that necessary i don't understand the
mechanics
to make a notice but it's funnier when
it happens slowly
well actually
i left the bullets
she's like clean kills she can't help
herself she loots everything listen i
left the bullets okay
wait i have a sniper ammo
um tell us if i was like the donation
popped up the overlays moved she's gotta
only be looking at the game that's what
it is
she's only staring at the video game
real gamer hours we understand
what the [ __ ] in the middle of
no man's land that is not how many
players are left language i don't know
how to tell
someone
doesn't understand ring's closing in
there's 20 it's 20. it's 20.
that could take a while
is that you reacting to the loot oh
not going to react to it prematurely
just it's just a little it was a good
loot box
oh i'll take that
[Music]
this game's too big
too many people in-game abundance of
mini bullets i could use them for my uh
smg
we got somebody swinging like spiderman
up ahead
it's possible she only has one monitor
that is a great point i like that that
is a great point she has to alt tab out
of it maybe
it's totally possible
nice
yeah get that dub
oh my god that went nowhere oh [ __ ]
got him oh cool would be an
underwhelming reaction
last year there was somebody who was
just like
[Music]
for like five minutes he was just like
what
like he was just so like concerned and
confused
it was amazing it took a really long
time for him to notice
oh god i'm getting killed
death could be good for us here though
i maybe want you to die
yeah [ __ ] your mother
you could bleed out and you and then you
could see this the street
let's do this
i'm so healing and then i'm gonna shoot
that [ __ ] to the left and i'm
gonna shoot that [ __ ] to the
right he's really
shooting
mother eff is out here he's getting them
he's getting them bleed out bleed out
i'm sorry but bleed out thank you kilo
water thank you so much
uh i have played fortnite three times
come on
come on you got time to eat
escalating you got time to eat but you
don't have to look at
donations okay
no plea don't don't
damn it i will wait until you notice
thank you stateless one
that you know what
if i could stream snipe right now i
would i don't you can't do that
fortnight when the match is already
underway
damn you
now you're all [ __ ] dead [ __ ]
he's so sassy
oh my
i'm just wearing nades
it's funny the way that i gamer talk
myself when i'm playing video games is
directly personal insults to me
never to anyone else eight eight eight
eight see some shots coming in
get ready girls
it's getting spicy
it's getting spicy will you reload the
goddamn gun jesus
not you
tilt a fight
just said that they donated again and
said notice me
[Laughter]
but he's right over that [ __ ] hill
it's probably in the bush
six
oh my god i so badly want them to win
and then
i need this level of energy in my and my
group of friends
he's so spicy
nice nice nice nice
don't you have to shake them
in
fortnite
bandages if anybody needs them
one squad left you're right you're right
you're right now i'm like even
like invested in this from like a
gameplay standpoint i'm gonna drop it we
have two people left you gotta kill
mother two people left gotta kill him
let's go i think there's two people left
yeah yeah yeah yeah
come on oh yeah come on this will be
amazing for you yeah i want you to win
so badly
oh there's no more shaking oh good to
know
you're not hiding from me i will murder
you
sorry about ads everybody of course you
can remove them if you want to
sub my subs generally go to tildefy
campaigns
but i also need to figure out how to
time them but i'm sorry about that make
it in alone
not really
there you go oh okay okay okay sad
does that do anything
come on
come on you better win you better win
come on
you're right this person has
they have
they have six viewers oh my god are you
serious lost 1 336 and they don't know
it's the opposite of like i hate raids
are you saying that because you got shot
going on
aimbots
aimbots for sure okay but hey it's not
all bad though is it
yeah tab out
holy [ __ ]
bro how did they know where i was
there's two thousand dollars here
ma'am
okay okay it played
nobody's
i wrote in a chat and said hey what you
raising money for
yeah
come on
i don't even know who it was
just give me the whole list hey
charlotte hazard how are you
okay i asked she saw what i said if you
look down there it's the starlight
children's foundation so if you just do
exclamation kids
okay okay okay it's gonna happen again
it's gonna happen again so just do
excellent
how much have you raised that's the link
you can use
and um wait
what
wait
what
i find it so funny wait what
oh my god oh my god
[Laughter]
it was
oh my god
it's easy to confuse it
justify don't worry about the bots thank
you so much
i'll be right back guys
oh my god
i think she had four dollars and it's
now 2 115.
he loves the shock
you love it
what happened
okay so you know that i'm raising money
for the starlight children's foundation
right
tiltify just came in and i now have two
thousand one hundred and fifteen dollars
and eleven cents
holy [ __ ]
the key and he alone did that
tiltify and i think maybe a couple of
other people
hello [ __ ] just seeing the
people cry makes me cry
every time oh god
[Music]
you guys just broke me
also yeah you guys uh
sorry about the second place thank you
everybody you hate to see it you hate to
see it
a lot appears
i'm gonna read it right now hold on one
second
i don't even have my
thing open
that explains a lot i have to go in the
chat
congratulations you made her cry you guy
you did
i love it this is so funny
[Laughter]
oh my gosh thank you so much
alana thank you so much you guys are
amazing
it's so sweet
holy [ __ ] i'm sorry oh thank you for the
reason thank you guys
hello welcome everybody
thank you so much we're having a real
wonderful stream right now we just made
this woman cry
i've been wanting to raise money for
these kids for a long time and this is
the first time i've had somebody come in
and
donate so do your thing dude this is so
lovely
um
okay so i don't know how many follows
that is but thank you all really talking
to tiltify right now everybody on
discord um who are coordinating with me
to donate thousands of dollars to small
streamers playing a variety of different
games she had four dollars before we
started
and raised money i think it was four
viewers as well unfortunately
um so we donated two thousand that's
what we're doing right now so thank you
thank you all for joining much for all
this i really made a cry and then i
cried because she cried
again
[Laughter]
oh it took such a long time it was
amazing
oh my gosh apparently you guys like
the hello
she did have four dollars ah
it's so good my face hurts again it's
only been
57 minutes apparently until my gosh the
other good cast crusaders about this
maybe i'm baby
oh you're so welcome codelink seriously
christmas tears you're 100 right thank
you everybody for the follows
[Music]
i thought i had it all set up but
definitely i will reach out for a
question for uh
yes yes
i've actually got to meet that man in
person and
um hello
he uh
he's an amazing dude and i actually got
to meet pantry elf in person as well
uh i guess what their name is because
my name is dj skids 24. that's fair
you're allowed to go by dj skits that's
fine
holy crap
you love to see it you'd love to see it
the vibes are very good
okay to be clear last pants on files the
people putting the farts in are us
that is my luck doing that
alert box
i'd love to make people cry you guys are
that one was great
yeah assassin we got a raid
i'm going to read the donations that
they actually put through because this
looks really funny
oh man
this is a little cheerleader
and anytime anybody does a fart in chat
i always that's so good
that's my signature sounds
that's what tiltify did that's so funny
amazing
oh man
incredible i love the dedication i
respect it very good
consuela that's my favorite one all
right he's gonna come up here in just a
second we are moving over to the next
one
[Laughter]
okay
oh my goodness
let me move you oh got a bunch of people
in here this one's going to be
interesting
hello [ __ ]
okay i'm fine
here we go are you making cookies this
is 50 for like only 10 minutes
we got we got a whole role playing
campaign going on here
they are raising money for
kentucky tornados they are a lot smarter
than me relief oh yeah actually red
cross just emailed me about that today i
had no idea that was happening
oh thanks
okay they don't have anything on screen
from what i can tell sleep he's in the
other room
oh you're right i shouldn't have center
there we go you've got two minutes
or i'm going to come don't hide anybody
she's accidentally full screen
i think wait is this oh do they rip they
try to write it out
on here now
[Music]
uh we just have to
there we go there we go okay and then
back i fixed it okay uh uh many many
please please help me with this
i'm not i don't know why you guys think
i'm smart i'm not okay i kind of want to
know what's happening here also
[Music]
she's gonna like take the paper and turn
it upside down
and look at it sideways
closer it's a christmas available
we know cinnamon goes in first what are
we gonna do make a sleeping motion and
then like make it this is actually a
really cute setup we're talking to this
guy uh cinnamon goes first yeah you guys
can totally abandon this and just you
know if it's i mean the music's also
very cute putting him to sleep is a good
idea
and if needs be i can campaign to
deliver it
i'm ready let's go let's go let's go
let's go yes you do a sleeper holder
watch the wwe wow okay claus
all right yes me and klaus can't deliver
or rosie can deliver
okay i don't know if he'd
be happy for reference
they
oh we just dropped it we just dropped it
it's not on their screen but we're gonna
drop it no wonder you don't work they
had a hundred dollars well
he wasn't always was there was their
goal was a hundred that goal was a
hundred and we just donated two thousand
five hundred you know snap the other one
in half just because they're a diamond
does and like
i feel a lot like this interesting to
see if they're looking at it for this
one you know without vanishing 100 goal
2 500 donated
thank you maybe i should do it again
just because it's not on screen i feel
like there's a good chance they won't
notice
well
okay so i'm pretty sure the cinnamon
goes in first because it says here but
the last time it was d d it was
pre-recorded
seven people one has to notice i
strongly agree
it says
it says they get soaked in water
and cold okay cool they have a mod
can everyone also give me an insight
check
you just gotta get your inside check i
get it i asked the chat what they were
raising money for and someone just
triggered nightbot
oh cool 13
11. how much money
have they raised
i know this better not be another
recording how would we know 14
i had a 14.
so rosie it could be looking at the
situation
kate you definitely know that cinnamon
needs to go in first and be soaked and i
don't know how to tell maybe you've
heard the other elves talk about it but
they're no they're in here but you also
remember that whenever the holly how
much are you trying to raise
um they're usually somebody typed back
to me in like a drink or something
oh yeah
[Music]
yeah so
the berries they definitely get bruised
okay they typed oh my god punch one they
typed oh my god it's for sure
pre-recorded
it's for sure pre-recorded
it's
i mean how else do you brew something
they said no it's life okay
where are the berries for the berries
like on the table or
what yes there and all the ingredients
are kind of spread out there on the
table so come on sticks
it's got to be more than that the holly
crimson berries and then the peppercorn
there are four
different um ingredients uh one of them
needing to be great nobody's seen it
needing to be chopped one needing to be
bruised and one needed to be soaked so
right now you know the soap hang on hang
on i know which one
let's check someone out if we can fix
them down
the order i posted might be
correct
they're just too good yeah right they
are too
soaked they are too into it
i think it's first we gotta play those
rolls and we gotta soak it and then we
got the walnuts and we gotta chop them
and then we got the holly
i guess we can take a good job and then
oh my god this is peppercorn and that's
gotta be all ground up okay okay let's
go let's see lost of it that's what i
think if we all go watch that's what
nenny thinks as she looks at the recipe
uh crosstalk steve sometimes he's using
his hands to grind the peppercorn into
into dust
do uh do we see water
yes there's a little pot of water maybe
on the skillet maybe
oh i just like my own twitch my bad my
bad here we go yeah it's already
bubbling it's already like life comes
out
oh actually yeah it's ready to be turned
the game monster i feel like could could
read it start soaking your cinnamon i
feel like you could
okay
it's cold water
i am so sorry to interrupt right now but
i think we just really need to do a
shout out
thank you
so much uh alana for your donation
twenty five hundred dollars
thank you thank you so much we'll take
it
amazing thank you so much everyone who's
coming and supporting us thank you
that's amazing
i think we were talking about that with
me brie like before we were like what
should we set wow that's amazing they
had a hundred dollar goal that's that's
awesome hell yeah yes thank you so much
everyone who's joined us who's great
much
american red cross benefiting um the
crisis really for the tornadoes so thank
you so much i must say i'm sorry very
nice work no no very nice no um is alana
viewing right now or
i you wouldn't be able to know
necessarily who is a viewer i am because
i was wondering hello okay hit me alana
wondering if there'll be a way to
i'm gonna i'll
i'll assume that's a huge win
for the party as
almost like divine inspiration
that's cool
yes you have all the ingredients in the
correct in the correct order yay we
influence the game
first um and so as you
commit to that and go through it
eventually it starts to
uh bubble in and boil
you hear santa getting up because this
is taking a while he's like
i don't have to come in and do
everything i respect how into it the way
they are though
at least it wasn't a recording he's like
right at the door
why aren't they all singing
ah and then he kind of walks out oh they
just subscribed
oh that's nice they didn't need to do
that
and so right now you guys are just my
real goal is to influence the dnd i
couldn't get that tarzan tattoo you guys
intentionally gave somebody else bit so
i couldn't have it
okay
let's jump over to another one here
and i look at him and go
i respect it also they all look very
cute
maybe
[Music]
here we go
this
is good one well then possibly 300. to
take care of this gentleman while he
said myself over here
so you're a wine merchant well you must
have planned
knowledge hmm
would you like to restaurant
you'll share
it's our signature
national children's alliance for your
supporting warm welcome
part of the party but
you still don't like him
he's suspicious
why are you being so suspicious
okay they are looking at shout outs that
must be full you can see them that's
celebrated wine right lansing you could
see it only it could be imitated
there it is
there it is
imitated imported
that's the word mm-hmm
sorry to keep you waiting drink up
dungeon is a good game
that's my hot take
right
this is a dandelion wine based cocktail
i asked the bartender to add calla lily
because it has a calming effect i know
you've been on the road for a long time
and cold drinks would be so i requested
less ice i hope it's to your liking
calming
is this what they have to close my
clothes overlay too which i think has an
effect on it
i like the voice acting i think
especially fine video games
because you know i'm interested in
monstat wines you're very interested now
just interested mind you they are
looking at chat we love that for us that
drinks made me realize just how empty my
stomach is oh so you're hungry too
of course oh how terrible of me
if i'd realized i would have saved some
pancakes for you
what just
um what
[Laughter]
um
um what
just happened
did i just
all right let me throw it to you let me
throw it to you
there you go
no freaking way to set up this person
hello everyone
thank you all for the following
it sure is hello
thank you so much oh my gosh this guy
seems so sweet
oh my gosh welcome on in everyone
no
this can't be hat no
thank you so much oh my gosh welcome
we're just gonna keep going with the
cowabungas all the way
[Laughter]
gosh thank you so much he has like bob
ross
i energy keep up
oh my gosh um
yes pokemon in everyone thank you so
much for that donation how do you raise
money for my friend
okay
um
we are raising money for the national
children's alliance
can you improve more of the follow sound
effect i know right it's just gonna keep
going
um especially because everybody
luna do you want to come here
this is absolutely thank you all thank
you all for coming in hanging out with
us
because of that donation you would put
us way over our original donation
um our original goal oh my gosh this is
the first night i'm doing this
thank you all oh my gosh
[Music]
i want to know what the pet is oh yes oh
my god
i think it's going to be a cat come here
oh my god look can you see things
can you say hi to everyone
it's not a cat
this is not a cat
can you say hi oh my god oh my gosh
everyone is here
what is pet name so much
[Music]
that is a cute dog oh my gosh she she
hates that so much what's it really
really hates that so much
but oh my gosh thank you all
so her name is luna
um
she is a pomsky
um oh my gosh
okay you know you've made it when
tiltify even
um
is following you now welcome on in
um so she's a pomsky she is
um half pomeranian half husky
that's got to be difficult and now we
have a bunch of people
she is
so kind
she is so fluffy sounds like a challenge
oh my gosh i love you all thank you
sounds like a bit of a challenge
thank you for all the follows and
everywhere
indeed um definitely
um raphael i love raphael for my
favorite
person myself
he's got the right amount of sex
and um he's got a great story arc
everything
those cowabungas are going to keep going
to be honest i don't know how to turn
them up so we're just going to keep them
going um leo is my second favorite i
love leo
a
everyone here thank you so much for all
of the
the follows
that's fair um i love the um
the arc of mikey of michelangelo
and you get to just like wear
hang out and hear somebody talk about
ninja turtles
how
lovely people are nice
i'm so calm watching them
brothers
i want to ask i hope this isn't rude we
just killed
we just wrecked our goal
so many people
um so
yes luna is
is our doggo um
at least one of them we do have another
one
with disabilities and they hope that
that's not on a treat uh take them
pulley but they have a tag if someone
asks me i would be down to check
somebody
come on in for the first time you like
to give the treats to our dogs um we
have them in our
old candy shop
luna is very cute
indeed i say thank you raiders
it's
luna knows to come running in because
she knows that she's going to get
treated that's a good idea
that's a good idea
okay thank you
um
so we're going to turn off the desktop
audio maybe that will stop the cowabunga
so we can chat a little bit
um what is my phys my invisible
disability um
that is totally fine um i welcome
everyone
to
um ask that um
my invisible disability is a reading
reading disability
um
so
um i my
disability is specifically in reading
comprehension
so i
i can read something on a page three
to like five times and still not
completely understand what is being
written
on the page um or try and make up
something that works
um when i was younger it was the fact
that i couldn't read very well i feel
like twitch must be like such a cool and
so
without being able to understand what
words specifically meant um they were
essentially just
hieroglyphics on a page
um
and so i had to make up my own
um
like meanings to words to sentences to
paragraphs things like that
and
um
and yeah so we had to do all of that
um
mike's hottest we've been able to
obviously get yeah not necessarily have
my master's degree which is why oh cool
i feel like i can speak so much is
because i've i've
we stan shadow splinter 21 gone over the
hurdles i've done what i needed to do um
and it actually really
um
the good story of uh when i was in high
school okay they essentially decided
that my disability didn't have another
one existed and that i had grown out of
and so i had to really advocate for
myself thank you so much push it
push myself to my limit in that um
favorite video game of all time that's
awesome that's a great question what a
nice person
just like
top five
um
favorite video game of all time
shout out to skyrim one of my favorite
video games all right we're gonna jump
to the next one here
all right
it looks so good they have raised 420
the next 50th of a 720 goal let the
memory live again i love it we are going
to start on september 11th it's in 1986
or 1983.
what do you mean
we are going to end up wrapping up
around here an adventure game
that i think i might know who this is
actually i'm sorry when i click close
game i thought that meant close the game
i really like this game it didn't
recognize the name very cute i feel like
maybe i know who
who she is
it is really good
and i enjoy it a lot
um hello nerf how are you how are you
oh don't i'm not sure thanks
i think i maybe well
i was gonna say enjoy your lurk but i'm
i'm actually headed out not sure oh no
because
he's tired and i got to work
so
we're here
get out of it get up
christmas chair
um it's been since
it's been sent
the applause didn't work and i don't
know why it picks every other time
but i caught that
and i saw a number
[Laughter]
i saw i i see i see weights i see
weights
when you're just wrapping up your stream
you just get a little donation
you'd love to see it
hey the people who said wait you ruined
it you shouldn't have said wait why'd
you do that it's very get out of there
very quiet now because now they think
that they're waiting for something else
just
i'm just it's it's
it's
you can't see my hands i'm doing the
cute thing i'm doing the cute thing
nerf
load the game back up i do think it's
very cute when people kind of freeze too
oh hello i'm sweating
oh i did it last year did i oh is that
how i know who it is
all right
[Music]
hello
welcome i'm gonna quick i'm cool with it
mute alerts because i will jump at every
single one of those alerts
hi
welcome
everybody to the chair force
how's it going everything okay noah no
i am a floating head i'm a floating head
today
um
alana
a lot of peers
i saw that number
has donated to our campaign
1420.
which hold up i can't i have to open up
i can't wait hold on let's move
somebody who's never smoked weed in my
life
hashtag what is it
that's not i didn't i didn't type that
correctly hold on hi my brain is in 50
places i've had a very um the aussies
have come you are welcome here you are
for certain thank you thank you
appreciate that hello appreciate that
means a lot hi i see gifted subs
i should probably not have the alerts
turned off or at least muted because
there is hi
i'm a flipping head
hashtag blaze it i love that
hi is she wearing
like a green suit
to make us welcome green screened maybe
she went out like a whole moth i'm gonna
wave you can't see my hands i keep doing
this and i'm like you can't see my arm
hi welcome handy tack it looks like it's
the first time you watch me live welcome
welcome welcome
i mean you can't see me to be honest
john cena um
are you wearing a green man suit i am
it's a good idea
i have my brain's not i might buy one of
those
thank you
for
for donating
such a wonderful blazer number
[Laughter]
i will do this shout out you would like
to go say hi
yeah so um
she had a shot of hot sauce as a
donation goal meaning she has to shop so
what is this for us rad is rise above
the disorder
every 30 dollars donated to rise above
the disorder it is covers a
therapy session for somebody who cannot
afford it and
one thousand four hundred and twenty
dollars covers
47. thank you a little over 47.
that's
amazing sessions
for somebody i think helping people out
that is love to see it
so necessary in this world um
i uh
i picked rad this year because my
god my catchphrase for 2021 was
everybody needs therapy because they do
um whether it is to
thank you
something or just to vent it out um
people just need to talk about sport and
game is indeed you just need to talk
about like uh this is gifted fake
feelings there you go um and i think
therapy is a wonderful way to do that uh
so having
47
covered right there but we're at hold on
let's do the math for all of them right
now because we have our total right now
is one thousand eight she doesn't have
to do multiple i can math what does that
mean
shots
61
therapy sessions covered through rad
and i think that is super cool i didn't
know that was a an organization that
existed that is good to know
that is so good okay let me demand i can
see your wonderful messages and i'm very
appreciative
we're going to do a hot a shot of hots
yeah
no kindness
only hot sauce um
but welcome thank you all for the
follows i saw some people did some shots
or nothing i very much appreciate that
um
you all are
wonderfully welcome here uh hotshot
yes
uh so let's do this
oh my gosh
thank you mister to be clear it is
making the donations help me personally
green screen i could not afford it
because but it is in partnership with
them it's such a cool thing that they
do are so good um the reason i'm in the
green screen suit is because our 306
oh
nice vacancy thank you for doing that an
absolute heart attack i will jump at
every single alert that happens um i
don't have a lot so i wonder if i should
say the
360 dollar goal limit was for no yeah uh
[Laughter]
every stream for the rest of the month
i'll be in a green screen suit so
let's do this it's frank's red hot sauce
which i have been told and yelled at at
any other charity uh stream that i've
done
um
it's not hot enough but it's what i have
and nc
nc second place ain't that bad
thank you so much
i feel like hot sauce would never be
good i
very much appreciate it and i love that
the applause worked for you
uh
all right all right
that's a lot um
yes let's go
i want to see it that was supposed to be
hot sauce no there i only have two hot
sauces
um so i'll i can do ghost pepper chips
if you'd prefer
did you pick that actually
i think oh damn it ncy
oh no
um
i don't want to drop this i can't do hot
sauce at all to be cleared i'm going to
drop she is much braver than me oh i got
a nice little uh
that's cute
all right napkin nearby
oh no this will probably go down in two
i'm just we're going to chase the hot
sauce with with ghosts oh god
why not
snort the chip oh good god no
i did i had to do this last night
and i have to do it again and you know i
question my life tauruses but it's for
charity and it's for therapy
that's true this isn't so bad in
comparison
i am vamping so i don't have to do this
can you tell
oh god
dude yes
that was not all of it
i appreciate the awesomeness not all of
it
appreciate the honesty
that wasn't at all that wasn't at all
well you need therapy after the shot and
chips oh yeah
yeah
that wasn't it all
give a give gifted an ulcer for charity
all right
all right she's gonna do it
i respect it
all right all right
i got this
okay
yeah it seems like that might have
sucked yep
next time do a shot of pepto
i might just need to sorry about that i
apologize
i'm gonna squint for a while
i'm just gonna say sorry lol
it can't even focus on my face that's
the amount of pain
very funny yeah
all right
doing the chips as well
have a good night alana thank you thank
you again i very much appreciate your
donation and uh your your
your whole crew coming on over here
i i appreciate it and thank you that's
you you guys are the crew a beautiful
and wonderful human being i think you
are
here hey thank you but i'm gonna eat
some ghost pepper chips
and then she's gonna do a lot
go to bed
you could just go to bed now you don't
have to just drink hot sauce for fun how
how's your stomach you don't have to
are they good
everything the floating chip is actually
quite a nice touch they are good they're
not that hot we'll be able to go out go
to sleep after all this
i will sleep
in pain
she seems like she's taking that they're
gross they're expensive i'm hearing a
lot of different takes on the chips
they're really hot but they taste good
wow there's a lot of different opinions
on these chips now i really want to try
this heck yeah you did nerp
tastes like paper yeah you did that
floating chip though it's so crazy that
it's just floating to my mouth i love it
i'm you've sold me on the green the
green suit okay we have one more this is
going to be our last one that can do
that let's go it's magic you'd say i
really should probably not be doing
all right
dude shout outs what is that god what
was his favorite game that's amazing ooh
[Music]
i ain't afraid of no ghosts this
seems my mommy
edited
i think this is edited what am i
watching
oh that was so bad i just have a hunch
this is edited i don't think ai made
this
oh
i'm so sorry
oh man i'm so sorry
i'm not sorry
thank you uh we hit our goal y'all
this is either an end screen or it's a
or it's a home queen come home
[Music]
um but i hope you enjoyed that little
video we had um thank you so much for
vibing with us oh i went to my game
but we're going to start fortnite in
just one second yeah but thank you so
much for watching
children's alliance
they have raised 400 above 500. actually
the beginning of last year
holy [ __ ]
hi alana
[Laughter]
oh my god
it's like it's a jump scare
hi
hi everybody hello
hi
thank you for the donation holy [ __ ]
uh hi thank you so much all of your
donation incentives have been met my
friends
thank you for the follow up cool okay
david i we thank you so much for being
here favorite thank you all thank you oh
my gosh hi
hi um my name is eric thank you so much
for your donation i love the amount of
people who just go hi
hi we're raising money hi national
children's alliance it's francis
hi
hi
hi
it's so funny
i love this double whammy system we got
going where they get the donation and
they go holy [ __ ]
and then the followers come through
um hi hi uh thank you so much alana i
appreciate that thank you tilta five so
much um
uh my name is eric i'm so sorry i'm
gonna i'm gonna mute my alert box i'm so
sorry the volume is good though
oh they had to follow a goal i don't
know you could even set those i'm
learning about how to use twitch today
um thank you so much alana and thank you
tiltify i thank you so much i love till
device so much i thought i muted this i
guess i didn't
how do i meet you i want to meet you
real quick there we go oh my god thank
you so much um i i love delta phi so
much
and just like tiltify you're a fantastic
platform that helps to do so much good
um if you're coming i also love culture
i didn't realize there's gifted subs
happening thank you for the gifted stuff
thank you for the follows everybody so
much i hope you're having a great
thursday or friday depending on where
you're at my name is sick i'm eric a
member right streamer here on my
facebook it's from smiling here on our
channel um if you're if you're
interested in sharing what you're
thankful for i'd love to know what
you're thankful
thank you so much like
this is what this is like like it comes
out so much good and i just thank you
like holy [ __ ] we literally exceeded so
much
i'm so sorry i i had to turn off the
book i'm so sorry but thank you so much
um we're actually about to get to play
some fortnite in just a little bit
um
oh my god
i gotta get itself raising money for um
the national children's alliance if
you're interested in learning more about
the organization please click the link
in chat um
leave the
leave the bonk on okay let me see if i
could put it back on the bonk is good i
like the box
one second i will do that just for you
oh my gosh
does that was that what you meant to do
yeah
okay i think it might be back on i think
you could do that thank you so much like
y'all literally what the hell this is so
crazy thank you so much i've never had
this hype train like this you might be
able to still do the bonk
uh literally thank you for the gifted
subs i can't even keep up with y'all
you're so kind y'all are so kind i'm so
thankful for people like you that just
want to give back you're awesome we love
you yay the bonk works beautiful yeah
the bunk works
oh the internet thank you may i see the
doggo absolutely jackson come here hey
there are more pets
there are more pets
this is the content that i see the dog
because he's actually in trouble but
this is jackson here
i thought that that was the dog and i
was like that's a very small dog stuff
hello jackson no no no drop it
hello good boy so he got in trouble yes
you're joining scratches oh my gosh
thank you so much mr e robot for the
five years of subscribing
another thousand what whoa thank you so
much uh
this is jackson he is our dog that we've
been that's amazing donated we've
adopted and just uh he's he's super
sweet he's a dog we adopted like five
six years ago he's very cute he's a
mascot on our channel um if you are
interested in
seeing him um there is a lot of cute
emails that we've had recently
commissioned he has really cute cozy
emotes thank you again alana thank you
so much like
thank you alana thank you anonymous
thank you thank you one second donating
stickers on my face everybody following
things on the wall raising money thank
you to tiltify
doing this again it's so much fun
that's an amazing person that obviously
yeah
literally always raising money by
five to make it super easy i love claws
my cause my cause like literally it's so
good and it does so much good for
the world for the communities and just
thank you so much we're already at five
thousand dollars this is [ __ ] crazy
y'all this is really crazy
um
i don't think we've had a single
streamer who doesn't just like swear a
ted which i also love we haven't even
played fortnight yet
i promise i'm gonna be so nervous okay
thank you for the thoughts
y'all y'all love the bonks for real
uh but yeah thank you so much wait oh
oh the face stick is that for donations
i see i see i see
jackson come here
he's bringing the dog back he's bringing
the dog back austin ninja trolls have
arrived hey zamora thank you so much
cowabunga welcome on in 5 000
literally ethan literally 5 000 that's
so that's so mind-blowing i really need
to get some kind of charge out of my
maid i didn't know you could do that i
would have thought that would not be
legal so jelly bean spins for y'all real
quick yeah and we're gonna do that real
quick um
i hope you're having a good time thank
you for vibing it's currently thursday
here we'd love to know what you're
thankful for for this thursday we'd love
for you to share some positivity i'm
thankful
for going on and so when we do our
thankful thursdays we try to bring and
acknowledge um a lot of stuff like all
of it like all of the things i think
personally
a positive outlook so we can kind of get
through the next weekend
i completely agree imagine for me i'm
thankful for it i completely agree the
community has already raised so much
money and then just literally
like so
much good was just done and just thank
you i know you have so many other places
to go to so please if you have to go
please please continue to do close my
cause it's such a great thing we love
tiltify so much and just thank you so
much for coming by he's so nice you need
to hang out with us if you want to we're
going to be playing fortnite just a
little bit i promise you some mediocre
game plays
but just thank you so much thank you so
much
everyone's so nice the donations it's
literally like just my oh you really oh
it twitch has their own pokemon emotes
oh my god
who is doing that that's incredible
one dollar donation
i just can't okay
okay
[Music]
thank you we are doing it that's
incredible
um thank you so much hi welcome on in
thank you for the phone incredible
favorite deep breaths
can you tell i'm okay thank you for that
thank you tell that i appreciate it it's
fine it's fine i appreciate the love
so much
thank you so much let's let's get some
hype
kaylina thank you i appreciate that
amazing if this is dollar's so kind
thank you so much for vibing
um okay we raise money i'm always a
little nervous to see how things will go
thank you for the donation
somebody just donated money money
no don't donate and donate money money
if you're gonna donate money please
donate here money money this thing's
overwhelming to you lots of simulations
yeah i you know i mean i i love the fact
that people want to do so much good and
just thank you so much um but i want to
make sure that i
acknowledge and appreciate y'all too so
alana let me make your name real quick
oh um but thank you again like
do i get a
uh thank you so much drop one item in
fortnight don't donate name i would like
a name can i get a name of an order i'm
going to get it to the charity please
yay
thank you so much for the hype that
sounds cool this is so cool we never had
hype train so thank you so much that's
so nice of you thank you
oh yeah yeah you're right they donated
to him that's what money money means
don't donate money buddy let's go
let's go okay let me put some actual
other music on real quick
let me put my favorite music on you can
do
we like children's dcm dmca fun
experience we love to do so much good
this is so cool honestly my face hurts
from smiling so much and doing all these
good things thank you
i'm so sorry if i miss anything like
that i've tried to turn alerts off so
that i don't like i just make sure that
i can pay attention to you you were
great sick america
you were great thank you so much for the
thank you literally for everything
you're the best
y'all are really y'all are really kind
y'all are really kind excited
i don't deserve it i don't deserve it
because you love you so much
um hey this is this is all please
appreciate it we're doing we want to
make do so much good and so thank you so
much for the donations and everything i
hope i'll i promise to make sure that i
breathe
[Laughter]
yay
i wish i could say thank you but i can't
type in his chat because i'm not
verified
on twitch
thank you very much
i appreciate you oh my gosh amazing uh
let me let me spin some beans actually
let me get uh
if you're interested in keeping up with
me after the outside of this um i'd love
to connect with y'all outside of this
you can do um follow me on twitter
youtube uh tick tock instagram um
anything like that but pronoun checks my
pronouns are he they i'd love to know
what your pronouns are thank you for
redeeming that beautifully shy i
appreciate that so much alana says hi
and that you're awesome
hi alana i hope you're having a good
thursday or friday great one for coming
by
um let me cut out some more ornaments
for y'all thank you
he's wonderful um wait how many stickers
did i put on i don't know if i put that
was me the last time i had to put
stickers on my face for a stream um okay
i'm gonna call it there we are gonna
raid the smoking dragons who i met
last year because of this exact stream
um i'm actually going to see them in
person really soon which i'm super
excited about we like became friends
through
through this which is awesome
so we'll go throw some love to them
thank you all for watching thank you so
much to tiltify for
organizing this again it is just the
nicest thing in the world it's so
wholesome and wonderful
well fifteen thousand dollars without
clothes my clothes the smoking dragons
look at them go
that's incredible all right um
let's go say hi
to them i love them a whole lot and i'm
sure they'll be stoked to see us
have a wonderful night everybody thank
you again tiltify and yeah hopefully we
do it again next year i would do it
forever
um i will have this up on youtube
in 24 hours and then i might do like a
highlights thing on christmas day as
well
all right
bye everyone
oh no that's the wrong no that's the
wrong channel
smoking that would have sucked hang on
smoking dragons
there we go we've done it
[Laughter]
all right good night everyone go send
them my love
i will see you next time bye